Mario Batali is a great chef I don't
know about past because I mean Julia
Child is a great home cook Alice Waters
the food genius of America I mean she is
the person who took America from being a
really pretty mediocre food place to
being a really pretty great food place i
would say i would say those are pretty
decent done getting a lot of trouble
there you know it thing is i think that
there are a lot of very talented chefs
out there in terms of people who have
changed the way americans eat there are
really just a few but different people
have done different things you know
wolfgang puck created the open kitchen
and restaurants that that shifted the
way chefs were seen in restaurants in
America and really opened the door to
the sort of celebrity chef culture that
goes on now which is good or bad
depending on you know what you think of
it but the the great chefs just from a
food perspective and what they did for
food I mean Mario Batali popularized
cured meats in America period he did
that and it's done I mean you go to any
city in America now and whatever kind of
hip swanky restaurant is carrying their
own meat it's wild it's really wild and
Alice water got people waters got people
into farmers markets and got people into
looking at things locally and got people
into believing that great products can
be produced in the manager
Oh